they they do not want need or find
average men
attractive
from his video post its clear plymouth
gunman jake davison was deeply resentful
of his lack of success with the opposite
sex in this day and age women have
nothing but options
at the very least his videos show
sympathy and understanding for those
involved in the so-called incel movement
of involuntary celibate men who are
deeply hostile towards those
particularly women who are sexually
active
the intel movement first rose to
international prominence in 2014 when
elliot roger murdered six students at
the university of california all because
he couldn't secure a relationship
i've been forced to endure an existence
of loneliness
rejection
and unfulfilled desires
in canada in 2018 alec minassian who
boasted of being an in-cell used a van
to knock down and kill 10 people in
toronto
they are
coming together in forums
and promote really deeply and
dehumanizing
rhetoric towards women
um a sense of their own entitlement a
sense of injustice
in the uk recent separate investigations
prevented these two men linked to the
incel movement from carrying out violent
action
anwar druik and oliver bell had both
spoken of their humiliation and
frustration with the opposite sex and
had attempted to make explosives
if plymouth killer jake davison was in
any way motivated by the incel movement
it will be of huge concern to
authorities as they try to track this
growing subculture of young men whose
sexual loneliness and rage is
increasingly manifesting in violence
mark white sky news